when we were back in the green room we
were talking a little bit about how
things have changed for science fiction
and fantasy how in earlier decades it
was more of our considered a kind of
peril literary genre couldn't get any
respect
now suddenly science fiction and fantasy
are at the center of the culture so what
do you guys think caused that to happen
and what kind of effect says it had you
have anything you'd like to say about
that change I'm not really sure what
close doesn't happen but it certainly
has been happening during my lifetime I
mean certainly when I was young if they
caught you in school reading a science
fiction book they'd take it away from me
the way you why are you wasting your
mind with that crap you know why don't
you read Silas Marner they won't know
when I was going to college there were
no college courses in science fiction or
fantasy and if depending on what
professor you got if you took a creative
writing course some of them would let
you write it but a lot of would not you
know this is creative writing we're
doing literature here we don't want that
genre crap so you got that but I have
seen this attitude to change I think in
the in the even as early as the late 70s
you started seeing courses in science
fiction and mostly in science fiction is
not so much for fantasy popping up at a
few universities I think Bowling Green
and in Ohio was one of the first and
we've heard about the people they're
doing doing that my voice has suddenly
gotten much louder and echoing ah yes I
am the voice of God and today it's it's
a it's a very different landscape we
have science fiction fantasy writers
winning the the Pulitzer Prize winning
other you know major prizes winning
National Book Awards Stephen King
winning a National Book Award even that
was controversial though it was
writers who did not like that and
protested against that bitterly so
things have changed a great deal and
from where I stand have changed for the
better the change is still not complete
even now you may have a you may have a
course in science fiction of course in
fantasy taught at your university but if
the course is you know survey of
American literature
there will be no science fiction books
in in the Canon there it'll be you know
between wolf force of Kayla Gwynn or
Roger Zelazny or some of the great
things well they will not be included
with Hemingway and Fitzgerald and Philip
Roth and Saul Bellow and the other
people so it's changed for the better
but the change is not yet complete
so the literary canon you think still
excludes science fiction and fantasy
writers even though you may have horses
in universities the focus yes the
official literary canon such as it is
which is kept alive mainly by academia i
think still excludes not only science
fiction fantasy but pretty much a woman
or fiction that's also true you know you
can take a course in mystery fiction and
some things and then you'll get Raymond
Chandler and Dashiell Hammett and some
of the others but you will not get a
Raymond Chandler novel taught at the
same time as the Great Gatsby in the
same course Stan what it gives about
this change well it was a English
department thing to a certain extent as
well as what we would called the New
York literary establishment but when
when you were in the modernist period
one of the things that meant was that
there was high high literature and and
pop literature and high literature was
high and pop literature was low and so
it was a kind of a class system but in
any case of snobbery and people like to
be snobs in a way because it clarifies
what's good and what isn't so but the
thing is that fantasy Gilgamesh the
first story that we have that's a
fantasy a really good one
and science fiction we are now all
living in a science fiction novel that
were co-authoring together so when on
the one hand you got realism well that
would be science fiction on the other
you have fantasy well that's our dream
life that's the stories that we tell
each other every day there was always a
good reason for science fiction and
fantasy to be central but there was a
short period of time where you had to be
doing what I call domestic realism to be
legitimate in the modernist system but I
will say the literature department here
at UCSD all the way back to 1970 which
is when I first encountered it was
always extremely welcoming to science
fiction crazies like myself mainly
because of the professors that I met and
so it was a matter of accident and
that's that's a good thing about UCSD
and maybe why UCSD has had so many great
science fiction writers come out of it
not out of the literature department but
at least out of UCSD yeah it should be
you know the division between high
literature and low literature culture is
actually a relatively recent thing in in
global history you know if you if you go
back to you know the Elizabethan theatre
Shakespeare was Shakespeare was not some
Queenie Twitty guy he was writing for
the ground like this what does anything
else he was including plenty of rival
jokes and sword fights and you know
exciting stuff in his plays that would
please the people who were just standing
in the pit and eating an onion because
they didn't they might throw that onion
and they were very conscious of audience
reaction I think a lot of the division
you know that produced this attitude
dates from Henry James and Robert Louis
Stevenson most of you know that story
from your lip courses I don't want to
bore you if you already do but I don't
think they know it again okay Henry
James had love for the Stevenson had a
celebrated literary quarrel at one point
which was brought on by James writing
the review of two books one of which was
Treasure Island by Stevenson and the
other which was a book about a young boy
I don't remember the author it was a
book about a young boy and provincial
France coming of age growing up and
James in this review contrasted to two
books and he
for me the pleasure of literature is
seeing the author's depiction of the
world and the recognition it brings in
me and I I go through it and I say yes
he got that right no I don't think he's
describing that right you know the
quality that ingredients to comment
shared experiences of people in the real
world experiencing real things and in
the case of these two books he said well
the the Treasure Island is far more
accomplished the prose is better it's
it's altogether better written but it's
it's very unrealistic and he said
differential book despite all of its
flaws it's about a child growing up and
that's an experience I have had I I have
been a small child trying to come to
terms with adulthood so I have been a
child but I have never been a pirate
hunting for buried gold and having sword
fights and dealing with the black spot
and get a yachtie and so therefore even
though Treasure Island is more
accomplished book the French book is a
more worthy book it's a more serious
book about a serious subject and the
other one is just sort of fun Stevenson
responded in the next issue the magazine
with a you know a rather famous
one-sentence thing here you know mr.
James says that he has been a he has
been a child but he has never been a
pirate company from very gold then
obviously he has never been a child and
James responded to that and and many
other people got involved and it became
a very long literary debate which the
academic and literary establishment of
the time subsequently decided in James
had won and from that point on
Stephenson and all of the Treasure
Island's and kidnaps and dr. Jekyll and
mr. Hyde and ELISA us were sort of
consigned to Jean or lettuce or Kitty
literature fun for children but not
about serious subjects in the real world
if you want to be a serious writer you
have to write about you know
coming-of-age problems in modern life
and you know things like that hopefully
as elegantly as possible
and therefore we had no creation
of genre literature's which was
accelerated by a growth of the Pope
magazines in America which made up rules
on room magazines detective fiction and
romance fiction and ranch romances and
westerns and Zeppelin stories that were
all very specialized but they were all
Pope and they weren't serious literature
with all science fiction and fantasy
writers all the mystery writers all
romance writers were all the literary
descendants of Robert Louis Stevenson
while the people who are writing
literary fiction are the literary
descendants of Henry James but I think
and I hope that the two sides having
been separated for a century are
starting to come together again
when they give Stephen King the National
Book Award he's definitely a descendent
of Stevenson and that gives me great
hope for the future